today's one minute monday is do
something nice I recently sat down with
a buddy of mine rich who was afraid of
putting his own videos up on facebook he
was afraid that his friends would see
those videos of him and judge him and
and and discourage him and laugh at him
so I said rich that's ridiculous I'm
filming you right now and we're going to
put this video up on your Facebook page
and once it went live I wanted to get as
much support for this as possible so I
reached out to Ed who was on my team i
noticed that Ed was friends with rich on
facebook and said ed can you please
leave a comment on this video just throw
some support behind rich I'm trying to
help him out could you do this favor for
me and Ed wrote back to say hey I've
been done and done you're a great guy
you put so much in helping others and I
really respect that so what just
happened here I was trying to do a good
thing for rich and I asked ed for a
favor and what happened was now ed has a
lot more respect for what he's doing he
loves being a part of the team he feels
closer to what we're doing he feels like
he's adding more value to the work that
he's providing as being part of the
belief team Evan Carmichael calm and and
it all came just because I was trying to
do a nice thing for somebody else for
rich and so when you do nice things for
people it comes back at you in so many
positive ways so I want you guys today
to find one person to help out has
nothing to do with your business's
saraly you're not looking for any angle
you're just trying to help them out
because I promise you it'll make you
feel great it'll make them feel great
and and it will come back you will reap
the rewards I promise you do it today
believe if you want to see more great
content to keep you inspired motivated
and believing check out my newsletter in
the link below